can apple's new studio display keep up
with the much more expensive pro display
xdr
well in many ways yeah
actually it can and there are five
specific ways that it is actually better
we've been testing and using the 5k
studio display for a week now and i've
personally owned the 6k pro display xdr
for over two years so in this video i'll
be comparing everything from display
quality flexibility features performance
and much more after many years of people
complaining apple finally made another
display but it cost five thousand
dollars and that was without a way to
mount it which costs at least 200 more
if you just buy the vasa adapter or a
shocking one thousand dollars for the
stand and the pro stand 9.99 and like
the mac pro they'll all be available in
this in the fall thankfully two years
later we have something that is still
expensive but way more attainable
especially for those of you guys that
make a living with your mac coming in at
1600 instead of 6 000 now this is for
the version that doesn't have height
adjustability whereas the xdr stand can
be adjusted and raised much higher but
for 400 bucks more you can get the
height adjustable model personally i
would rather get a little base if you
need a few inches higher because the
distance from the wall will change while
you are adjusting it because of that arm
so if you have a small desk it could end
up feeling a little bit too close to you
now with that said i ended up getting
used to it sitting slightly too low for
my taste after a few days of use and
that's without having any neck or strain
issues or anything like that
so we are just going to leave it the way
it is now the xcrs luxury stand attaches
with ultra strong magnets and can also
be set vertically which is something
that you cannot do with the studio
display even if you buy the more
expensive stand the only way to do this
is to get the vasa option that
thankfully doesn't cost anymore and then
get your own third-party stand now as
far as the build quality both are
excellent being built fully out of
aluminum and glass this is why so many
people have been asking apple to build
another display because most monitors on
the market are made out of cheap plastic
with a plastic film on the front which
has lower contrast and more reflectivity
than the glass with these displays with
that they not only look good but these
monitors are super stable on your desk
compared to the previous 5k the apple
sold from lg now if you've used higher
end monitors before that can get really
bright you will know that some of them
actually have fans that you can hear now
both of these have dual fans but they
are silent the studio display sucks and
air from the vents on the bottom that
cover the full length and then exhaust
them from the top the xdr on the other
hand has that iconic cheese grater
pattern on the back that helps cool it
down and the crazy thing is that the
pattern is the reason for most of the
thickness of the 6a xdr so with that why
in the world is a studio display so
thick when it doesn't have those well
there are two reasons the first one is
that this display has a literal iphone
11 processor in it with an a13 chip
that's paired with 64 gigabytes of fast
storage and four gigs of ram now i'm
going to touch on this in just a bit but
the second reason is because apple may
use this frame for an upcoming imac
which is also possibly why it has so
many vent holes on the bottom and the
top even though it does not need that
because it doesn't have mini led now for
some reason apple decided to use a
mostly non-removable power cable linus
tech tips did yank it out with a lot of
effort so you can actually remove it but
apple designed a tool specifically for
removing this which is just dumb why not
just use a normal plug like the 6k pro
display xdr has now both these connect
through thunderbolt with three extra usb
type-c ports to use as a hub now this is
where the studio display is very
impressive somehow apple is able to get
around the previous five gigabit per
second bandwidth limitation since the 5k
display uses so much data now possibly
because of the a13 doing processing i'm
not sure i have no idea but what i do
know is that technically the ports are
twice as fast than the 6k pro display
xdr and in the real world i noticed the
same exact difference when i'm testing
with an external fast ssd now with that
said the 6k actually only runs at usb
type 2 speeds when connected to my mac
pro's vega 2 graphics card because of
different limitations and you don't have
that issue with the studio display and
the benefits of the studio don't stop
there with the xdr i had to spend over
200 on speakers well i guess i didn't
have to spend 200 bucks on those but i
also didn't want some junk speakers if i
spent so much on the display so you're
gonna buy something decent that sounds
good
whereas the suit display has six
speakers built into it four of them are
force canceling woofers that actually
have really nice deep bass surprisingly
deep as well as two speakers for the
higher frequencies just like the new
16-inch macro pros the sound quality is
very very good take a listen for
yourself
[Music]
now i have to say it doesn't get as loud
as an imac but it does sound more
natural and with deeper bass and so for
most regular people these speakers are
more than good enough for daily use and
they also support spatial audio with
dolby atmos support and with hey siri
using the built-in mics here's the
quality of the 1080p webcam that's built
into the studio display as well as the
triple microphones now this actual
webcam is really wide it's center stage
same one that's built into the ipads
which means that right now when i'm
recording with the application that
doesn't support it you it actually just
crops in a lot to look like a normal one
but you guys could see the quality is
not great we have some noise not as good
detail but it does allow you to use the
center stage feature to go much further
away it will auto adjust and then if
somebody else walks into the frame
well you will see them actually show
vadim just like it showed right now so
it is nice to have it built in but i do
wish the quality was a little bit better
the 6k xdr doesn't have a webcam or
microphones built in so you once again
need to spend more and then you could
choose between something junky or
something good like logitech's 4k pro
webcam that can magnetically attach to
the xdr which does look fairly clean but
of course that is another add-on i have
to say that it is nice to have
everything you need built into the
display to have a nice clean setup to
not to spend extra money but with that
said well let's get into what makes the
xdr worth that 6 000 price tag the image
quality now yes 6k does sound like a lot
more than 5k it has just over 20 million
pixels whereas the 5k studio has just
under 15 million so in the real world it
is nowhere as big of a difference when
you're comparing say 4k to 5k and with
that since the pro display is larger at
32 inches you are actually not getting
any extra detail those extra pixels are
needed to keep the same 218 pixels per
inch which apple considers retina
quality so the actual sharpness and
detail on these are identical both of
these look really really good really
detailed at normal viewing distances
unlike a 4k display which looks a lot
worse at this size and distance now the
xdr's biggest selling point is that it
can sustain a massive 1 000 it's a
brightness across the entire display all
at once with no limitations and up to
1600 nits in certain scenarios and
depending on what's being shown this is
crazy because most 4k displays even the
best oled ones
they actually max out at less than a
thousand that's only for certain little
specks of
highlights on the screen if you have a
full screen brightness it'll be at like
300. and if you're comparing that to
most budget 4k displays that people say
you just buy that while you spend so
much money well those are running at
about 300 nits nowhere near that now
apple's new studio display disappointed
many people because it is not mini led
so it cannot hit those crazy high
brightness levels many people said that
it has the same panel as the 5k imax and
lg's six-year-old ultrafine 5k display
that has the same panel as the imax and
that is why so many people were so
bummed out and disappointed but that is
simply not true the studio display is a
hundred nits brighter at 600 nits which
is extremely bright for an sdr monitor
but at the same time it actually manages
to have better contrast and way less
reflectivity as well this is clearly a
new updated panel that looks a lot
better and it can also support apple's
edr for really good hdr performance
being a regular lcd panel so the studio
display actually does a surprisingly
good job compared to other displays but
of course the pro display xdr absolutely
kills it with its high brightness for
hdr content with highlights that really
stand out they just pop so much and then
having the full screen brightness that
can literally blind you in dark
environments and with that if you are
watching in the dark you will notice
that the studio display will look great
now not as bad as the imax and other
displays but nothing like the oled
levels of blacks with the pro display
xdr however if you're watching in normal
lighting environments the blacks on the
studio display look surprisingly good
for an lcd display now when you're not
viewing or working with hdr content the
pro display xdr will max out at 500 nits
just like all of the other macs but the
studio display is brighter at 600 which
i really appreciate as it can help
battle reflections and it is really nice
and bright rooms both of these can be
purchased with nano texture to decrease
reflections with way less of a detail
hit compared to matte displays but this
option costs a thousand dollars on the
prospect xdr where it is only 300 on the
studio display with that said most
people do not need this and without it
you will get the full quality of the
display and with the extra brightness of
the studio display it comes out on top
as far as color accuracy both of these
come with dci p3 color accuracy and are
factory calibrated and they have
reference modes depending on the color
space you want to work in but the xdr
has that hdr mode built in and both
these are 10 bit displays with over 1
billion colors if you're somebody that
needs to accurately edit hdr content
then you need the pro display 6k or some
other third-party option that can
support higher brightness but for most
people the studio display simply makes
way more sense it is way better in most
ways and you have all the conveniences
of the built in the speakers you know
the microphone the webcam and all of
that for a much lower price i know the
studio display has gotten a lot of hate
because it is still sdr and because it's
not cheap but prices on everything have
gone up a lot in the last six years
since the lg 5k was released and this
one cost 300 more you're getting a lot
more than three hundred dollars of value
compared to buying that still for
thirteen hundred a lot more built-in
better build quality better resale so i
would say that if you can afford it i do
not think that you will be disappointed
pick one up we'll have a link down below
you will be happy now if you can afford
the 6k version i would still say
pick the 5k version up don't buy that
one unless you need hdr and if you want
to spend that much money i would see if
you can hold off a little bit longer for
apple to update it with some newer specs
and newer features so there you guys go
there's a full comparison i do think
that the studio display is the better
display in most ways but let me know
your thoughts down below click that
circle above if you want to help us
reach our goal of 1 million subscribers
we would definitely appreciate it and
check out one of those great videos
right over there this has been max with
max tech and i will see you in the next
video
[Music]